let's see let's go to our next caller
from the eighth 1/8 area code caller
from eight 1/8 who's there 8 1 8 million
have us mutaters hey good morning yes
hey David canary yes I can hear you hey
so for the 2020 election
I was just wondering on your views on
Bernie sander and whether it would be a
correct choice for the presidency or
what direction we should maybe look
towards well Bernie has not announced
his candidacy right now although there
are a number of articles saying that
he's eminently going to announce so I
guess you know if you're asking me do I
agree with Bernie on policy yeah he's
one of the people closest to me when it
comes to policy for sure but I'm not
sure if that's really what you mean like
are you asking sort of a different
question yeah yeah no that that's um
that's something um but like you do you
think he's strong enough to to beat
Trump because Trump's bases right now
very divided and strong and you know us
that are on the other side of the coin
Oh most of our thoughts are kind of
scattered and with David I mean with the
guy the CEO from Starbucks how high that
has the possibility yeah
that has a possibility to definitely
shift uh I guess the Democratic Party
and the independent party in favor of
the Republicans listen I get that we
have to ask the question can X person
beat Trump I just think it's way too
early to be playing that game because
that's how we end up with with bad
decisions and I think you're smart to
point out you said that the Trump base
is divided and strong but I think you
mean United and strong right yeah yeah
you know yeah because they are United
and strong and half the country doesn't
vote I don't actually think that this is
going to come down to picking a Democrat
that can pick off some Trump voters I
think this is merely about picking a
Democrat who allows the enthusiasm for
removing Donald Trump to sort of run
through them they need to be a conduit
people's desire to remove Donald Trump
which simply allows the left to go and
get people who weren't planning to vote
to vote we're going to win on voter
turnout we're not going to win if it
depends on convincing Trumpets to vote
for Bernie or or Elizabeth Warren or
whoever else so I would not not even
think about it in those terms I see all
right David well thank you very much
ma'am I assure you we see a car home
thank you so much great to hear from you